[Aplausos]
nas pequenas e historietas da vida vem o
recital minhas rimas no sol nascente em
santos
me preparo para tomar um banho sempre
disposta a não se render aos encantos de
quem espera sempre alcança
quem acredita sempre alcança nem
acredito
logo pequena esperança mas na labuta
diária eu sei quem sofre
lavo louça faço comida o meu salário
acaba igual essa correria estuda mineiro
que me diziam estudei mas estou aqui eu
não entendo oportunidade de serviço teve
de mons
cozinheira e faxineira porque não me
contratou no shopping
eu não entendo esse você me tanto pra
pagar um curso de secretária
mas se quem tem dentro do escritório opa
desculpa cometi um evento e sim já limpa
tudo e lavar o banheiro
os dias passam os meses vôo e os anos
também se vão e eu aqui na mesma
situação de m e stfc a doméstica
se fosse por opção tudo bem eu tenho
várias amigas que estão nessa situação
já se conformaram mas eu não quero
conquistar novos ares
por favor moça me deu uma oportunidade
eo moço me disse você segue esse
corredor vai reto vire à esquerda entra
naquele quartinho que a vassoura está à
sua espera
seja bem vinda bom essa poesia escrevi
em 2011 e vou contar o porquê que eu
escrevi essa poesia
hoje eu vim pra falar sobre o sucesso da
página e empregada doméstica
a página que eu criei no facebook a
página ela surgiu em julho de 2016
isso mesmo esse ano ela ainda nem
completou quatro meses e como eu criei
essa página não foi nada programada
estava em casa de férias devido à
correria do dia a dia às vezes a gente
nem tem tempo de pensar e ver tudo que a
gente já conquistou na vida então eu
peguei a linha um dia no meio da minha
vida corrida e fiquei bem
dali no sofá lembrando de tudo o que eu
conquistei o meu sonho era morar próximo
da pá da praia e hoje moro próximo da
praia quase em frente e lembrando de
tudo o que eu conquistei também vêm
algumas lembranças de quando eu era
empregada doméstica e como utiliza o
facebook com/odiario né eu coloco tudo
que acontece na minha mãe até briga
comigo menina tudo depois no facebook é
amanhã é meu novo diário e aí eu resolvi
compartilhar as coisas que me veio à
mente porque eu fui empregada doméstica
durante sete anos e avisei pra galera
olha pessoa pessoal é me veio à
lembrança alguns relatos vou começar a
postar isso no facebook vou utilizar a
hashtag empregada doméstica
pra que esse caso outras pessoas já
passaram por isso também compartilhem e
aí dá pra eu ficar seguindo que todo
mundo escreveu sempre falando no passado
pra minha surpresa em menos de 24 horas
isso viralizou muito rápido né e aí logo
em seguida eu coloquei meu primeiro
relato o meu primeiro relato na internet
foi referente ao meu último emprego como
doméstica na cidade de santos
isso em 2009 é eu fui contratada para
ser cozinheira ea minha patroa me
impedia de me alimentar da própria
comida que eu fazia eu tinha que trazer
os talheres
eu não poderia eu não podia utilizar o
copo na casa dela e nem o banheiro na
casa dela tinha banheiro para as
domésticas mas teve um dia que esse
banheiro estava quebrado e ali eu fiquei
nove horas sem poder utilizar o banheiro
e isso uma pessoa que sempre falava que
eu era tratada como se fosse da família
a partir desse momento quando eu
compartilhei esse primeiro relato na
internet viralizou muito rápido e aí eu
sentia necessidade de criar a página
porque eu comecei a receber tantos
relatos que eu achei que ia receber só
histórias do passado e não histórias de
hoje 2016
a página tem menos de quatro meses como
eu já falei ela tem mais de 4 mil
acessos é mais de quatro mil emails
relatando essa história
eu dei entrevista para diversas diversas
mídias
tanto a mídia internacional quanto à
mídia nacional
bbc de londres a tv dw alemã e várias
outras
o que eu fiquei super surpresa quando eu
falei com esses repórteres via skype que
todos todos todos eles se emocionaram
muito quando eu comecei a falar da
situação das domésticas aqui no brasil
e aí eles conseguiram se recompor e eu
comecei falar dessas histórias porque o
trabalho doméstico fora do brasil ele
tem um outro simbolismo né as domésticas
lá são mais valorizadas ele elas ganham
é por ora é por ora então totalmente
diferente aqui no nosso país
eu recebo também nessa minha página
vários anúncios abusivos que anúncios de
emprego que intitulei como anúncios
abusivos por exemplo um anúncio que eu
lhe era para a trabalhadora e trabalhar
de segunda a sexta das 8 da manhã às 18
horas
ganhando 380 reais por dia não semana
muito menos por mês
trezentos e oitenta reais por mês
essa que é a nossa condição aqui no
brasil existem domésticas passando por
essas condições ainda hoje existem
domésticas que estão sendo impedidas de
se alimentar e também não ganha um vale
alimentação existem domésticas não
podendo aí é utilizar o banheiro e
sofrer sofrendo todas essas atrocidades
que eu sempre mencionou na página
mas durante sete anos foram várias
histórias de opressões porém em uma
única casa que eu encontrei algo que eu
chamo de tratamento humanizado que é a
regina e logo quando eu cheguei na casa
dela eu comecei a limpado o costume de
tudo que eu sempre fazia e eu entrei
numa sala que tinha uma biblioteca
gigantesca e eu sempre gostei de ler por
em livros até hoje em dia custam muito
caro ea minha mãe doméstica o meu pai
carteiro não tinha condições de comprar
os livros que eu queria
e aí eu fiquei muito emocionada de ver
tantos
livros e comecei a folhear isso vira uma
prática diária então o que eu fazia
chegava na casa dela arrumava tudo
rapidinho deixava meia hora para limpar
a prateleira né e ali fica sentada me
deliciando com aqueles livros e para
minha surpresa a resina entra na sala
eu fiquei nervosa talvez pálida comecei
a chorar
eu era muito nova e não sabia nada da
vida e sabendo das experiências que já
tinha passado no passado eu fiquei muito
nervosa e aí ela senta ali comigo e
falou que está fazendo foi desculpa eu
comecei a atirar porque e vi que tinha
um livro e exato e ali eu fiquei muito
nervosa ela falou nossa você tem
interesse em estudar eu falei sim o meu
sonho é ser professora de história é
desde pequena ouvia muitos livros eu
quero entender a história do mundo e ali
ela começou a me indicar vários textos
que em 2009 quando o ingresso na
universidade
eu cheguei a ler na universidade também
então isso que é que eu chamo de
tratamento humanizado em 2009 foi muito
difícil conciliar a universidade com as
faxinas porque eu ingressei na
universidade estava tudo resolvido não
eu tinha que pagar a mensalidade e
graças a alguns professores de diversos
amigos de classe que me auxiliaram
resumindo alguns textos eu prestes a
entrar na sala para fazer prova que é
muito difícil conciliar é um trabalho
totalmente pesado com é os estudos e aí
pra quem acha que eu fui a primeira a
falar sobre essas questões de levantar o
tapete da família tradicional brasileira
e mostrar que a escravidão ainda não
acabou
existem mulheres trabalhando em
situações análogas à escravidão eu não
fui a primeira fazer isso é só utilizar
a internet como ferramenta mas existiu
nesse mundo nesse brasil uma mulher
chamada laudelina de campos mello mulher
preta como eu que na década de 60 criou
o primeiro sindicato das domésticas e
ela era conhecida pela mídia da época
como t
das patroas tudo isso quando eu comento
e expõe algumas se alguns relatos é a
pessoa fala nossa é muito pesado né
sim hoje eu vim aqui pra gerar incômodo
porque eu acredito que só através do
incômodo que a gente consegue mudar
algumas coisas
ninguém vai seguir o caminho com uma
pedrinha no pé né porque a grande
maioria das trabalhadoras domésticas no
brasil 79,6 por cento de acordo com o
dieese de 2013 são mulheres pretas e
essa não pode ser a única condição da
mulher preta
esse lugar é um trabalho como qualquer
um sim 53% da população é negra também
né
aqui no brasil e 79 por cento são de
doméstica
esse serviço não pode ser hereditário
para a mulher preta porque eu falo que é
o serviço hereditário
a minha avó foi doméstica
a minha mãe foi doméstica e eu também
fui doméstica
quando eu cheguei pra falar pra minha
mãe que eu seria doméstica ela começou a
chorar porque eu fiquei sem entender mas
ela já sabia que tudo que ela passou e
enquanto trabalhando nas casas de
família aqui no brasil também eu também
passaria por que eu demorei também muito
tempo para entender que currículo com
foto e boa aparência nunca é preta
quando eu concordo entende isso e
começar a entregar currículos sem fotos
aí me chamava pra pelo menos uma
entrevista tomava um susto isso depois
de formada tá tomava o susto de ver
minha experiência de ter estagiado isso
e aquilo e tal e aí é você mesmo
sim eu sou mágica
e eu sempre falo que o que era a casa
grande no passado são os apartamentos de
luxo hoje o que eram as os escravos
domésticos no passado e é um passado não
tão distante tá tá bem pertinho da gente
são as empregadas domésticas hoje a
senzala moderna é o quartinho da
empregada ela chegou correndo aflita e
nervosa porque eu fiquei esperando muito
tempo para chegar sexta feira dia de
pagamento eu escuto ela entrando com o
carro barulhinho da chave abrindo a
porta à nossa minha patroa chegou
e aí quando eu chego já trabalha já com
a roupa de embora só esperando ela me
pagar a ela chega e fala menina foi tão
corrido nossa esqueci de tirar o seu
dinheiro segunda-feira te pago a senzala
moderna é o cursinho da empregada
minha menina eu criei ela desde
pequenininha com tanto zelo e carinho a
mãe dela sempre a trabalhar não tinha
muito tempo pra ela mas todas as
necessidades que ela passava e sofrerá
eu estava ali eu só queria ver ela
casando foi isso mas infelizmente não me
convidaram para o casamento mas como eu
sou audaciosa coloquei minha melhor
roupa
fui na igreja fiquei lá escondidinha e
pude ver a menina casando porque a
senzala moderna é o quartinho da
empregada é natal tô vendo minha falta
vem da família da minha patroa se
divertindo todo mundo feliz e me bateu
uma tristeza porque é natal eu não estou
com a minha família porque a senzala
moderna é o coxinha da empregada
o pior momento da minha vida é quando o
meu patrão vai trabalhar
ele vai trabalhar nele leva a a a esposa
dele para o trabalho fala para a esposa
dele que tem no trabalho porém ele volta
pra casa pra minha sede a e aí a única
solução que eu tive era tirar cópias de
todos os cômodos
então se eu vou limpar o quarto eu me
tranco
se eu vou limpar o banheiro e
e assim eu consigo fugir dos assédios
dele que quando eu falo que vou mudar de
emprego minhas amigas fala menina
resiste se ganha 1.800 reais por mês
você nunca vai ganhar esse valor em
outro lugar e eu fico aqui resistindo
porque também deixei meu filho no
nordeste eles precisam desse dinheiro
porque a senzala moderna é o quartinho
da empregada
acabei de chegar um serviço novo trouxe
o meu potinho de sorvete porque o
potinho de sorvete é meu clínico e aí eu
estava ali na salinha de na área de
serviço apertada pedir o meu pai tinha
de servir de sorvete e fez o número 1 ea
minha patroa havia fiquei muito
assustada e ela começou a chorar e falou
por que você tá usando um pouquinho de
sorvete utilizar o banheiro que isso que
está acontecendo não o seu banheiro após
utilizar não porque nas outras casas que
eu trabalhei não pôde utilizar o
banheiro e não tinha banheiro da
empregada por isso que eu trouxe potinho
porque a senzala moderna é o coxinha da
empregada
hoje estou aqui contrariando as
estatísticas para algumas pessoas no meu
lugar seria lá na faxina porque quando
eu falei pra minha patroa que eu queria
estudar
sabe o que ela falou pra mim ela falou
assim menina você tem que ser feliz onde
você é
presta atenção sua volta foi doméstica
sua mãe também não foi no méxico e já
está predestinado para sua família
servir
então você tem que ser feliz servindo
então estou aqui contrariando as
estatísticas mulher preta
gordhan reta
ele fere canto
[Aplausos]
mulher pressa gorda professora
periférica e reto ao meu lado eu não
estou sozinho aqui hoje atrás de mim tem
6 milhões de domésticas que deveria
estar aqui ao meu lado e que em algum
momento elas estarão tudo o que eu faço
a correria que a minha vida não pensando
em dinheiro que a gente não tem grana
mas só de ver que 6 milhões de
domésticas estão sendo representadas
agora e que muitas não estão me
assistindo mas não poder assistir porque
elas estão a 'limpa' duelo é isso que eu
quero provocar nesse momento porque todo
mundo é que deve ter vários patrões
várias patroas e algumas domésticas né
se cada um levar essa idéia de
conversarem humanizar as relações
a gente vai diminuir um pouquinho de
desigualdade neste país porque em outros
países várias domésticas trabalham e
estudam e aqui ainda há esse trabalho de
doméstica tem como propriedade privada a
gente consegue ver nos aeroportos porque
que abatem que está vestida de branco é
uniforme sim pra poder identificar ela
então dentro de casa
será que a patroa não sabe que ela é a
babá mas não é pra deixar bem claro
quais são os lugares de algumas pessoas
nesse país
então estou aqui contraria as
estatísticas não foi fazia que estou
falando por seis milhões de domésticas
[Aplausos]
i
[Música]
[Aplausos]